do what the [ __ ] happened the guy who
did this subway things Jared says he
finds middle school girls hot some chick
was taping him for [ __ ] four years
he's caused a lot of pain its pain that
will never go away
what for saying that he must have gone a
little further than that on Wednesday
Fogle admitted that he had sex with at
least two minors and obtained child
prefer not pornography of 12 other
children as young as six years old boy
dude is anybody safe can anybody go
wire-to-wire without the [ __ ] hammer
coming down Jared Fogle is a monster
he's a monster that's what she said how
funny is it that I was just talking to
you guys about eating right and getting
in shape and I go look at Google [ __ ]
news so I got something to run my
goddamn Yap about Jesus Christ and he
looks like DeRosa
that's [ __ ] hilarious you got to be
[ __ ] kidding me
Fogle served as subway spokesman for 15
years ever since he first appeared on
television claiming that eating the fast
food change sandwiches and working out
helped him lose more than 200 pounds
please he probably lost that money
running out the back door when the
parents came see this is dumb I
shouldn't be doing this this guy's not
being convicted of anything oh but he's
completely [ __ ] he better have done it
I mean I hope he didn't for kids sake
but I mean he's [ __ ] now it's over
what's he gonna go over to blimpy hey
everybody I'm wrong Lee a cute accused
child molester Jared Fogle and I'm here
to tell you that Blimpie's makes you
even more skinny and what the stress is
sitting there you know thinking I was
gonna go to jail for that [ __ ] and get
gang-raped because that's what happened
oh god Jared Jared what did you do oh my
god
if he if he [ __ ] did this [ __ ] and
he's guilty and he goes to jail do you
have any [ __ ] idea
what's good I love that they put him in
protective custody for how [ __ ] long
you know what I mean
I figured maybe eight ten year he's
[ __ ]
literally oh my god they'll descend on
him hey Jerry what he want the six of
the 12 inch I [ __ ] kill myself ah
there's got to be a way to do it he's
too [ __ ] skinny now to hang himself
just sit there twitching around like a
[ __ ] goddamn fly they got its wing
ripped off how do you kill yourself when
you're shaped like a pencil oh god what
are you doing oh I know I do I'd [ __ ]
break my glasses and I Jam one of the
pieces in my neck just bleed out in the
cell there you go the see there's always
a way you know they put somebody in a
confined area that they're gonna come up
with something you gotta be [ __ ]
kidding me I don't understand why before
the guys convicted that his face is all
over the [ __ ] place I don't get it
because if this guy didn't do this [ __ ]
was like what the [ __ ] I was talking
about last week about the hockey player
there it's like if they didn't do it
they completely [ __ ] they [ __ ]
either way either they did it and
they're going to jail and getting
gang-raped you know what you know that's
what you get for doing that [ __ ] but on
the other side if you didn't do whatever
you know what how do you make your money
then I don't know you gotta be [ __ ]
kidding me wow wow Jeb Bush Donald Trump
unapologetic for anchor baby language
okay I'll be honest with you as far as
like you know offensive [ __ ] anchor baby
that gets pretty [ __ ] light you know
what I mean there's no racial epithet in
there there's nothing homophobic anchor
baby it's the baby that gets you in here
you know you putting down roots right
how about a root baby a root a baby I
hate that [ __ ] report shut the [ __ ]
up you're offensive
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you work for some
corporate goddamn news news [ __ ]
paper quit acting like you're giving out
the facts you jerk-off you write about
what they tell you to write
Wow that's what you should have done you
read what they tell you right about then
you go on you cash those checks don't
you you go go buy yourself an Audi right
or a BMW some German sedan it lets the
Broads know you [ __ ] you know you're
on the dolfe you gotta be [ __ ]
kidding me man Jesus Christ you can't
trust a former [ __ ] fat [ __ ] who's
eating sandwiches to be around your kids
honestly who can you trust
there have been a great [ __ ] segue to
go into my advertising where the [ __ ] is
it it's over here
not Jesus everything's just falling
apart on me here all right it's time for
some advertising I mean what else what
else do you do after you talk about the
former fat [ __ ] who became a skinny guy
and then allegedly Jesus Christ anyways
I had a [ __ ] you think you're gonna get
away with something like that all right
be one thing if you with a spokesperson
for Wendy's like that old guy then he
could just say no no just dressed just
Anna